à voir les bateaux de pêche devant le
bourg de sainte luce
ici les pêcheurs ne sont pas nombreux à
avoir pris la mer les casseurs attendent
avec impatience le retour des marins
pour savoir s'ils auront du travail
permis ti les premiers équipages sont de
retour et le constat est sans appel la
récolte est plutôt maigre
malgré les nombreuses re a plongé vers
le vauclin là on est allé pêcher nous
les super les yeux c'est super à main ou
les prendre c'est difficile avec comme
je vous ai dit l'eau salée tout c'était
impossible donc on est obligé d'aller
c'est tombé de retourner sur sa cuisse
pour tenter de la houle et du courant
voilà les ingrédients pour une mauvaise
visibilité sous l'eau à quelques pas de
là le constat est le même mais
heureusement la qualité est là les ours
en sont suffisamment mûrs la quantité de
grenade est satisfaisante
oui c'est le jeu c'est sûr que toute
l'année on exploite la mer mais a il ya
un jour pour le pêcheur et puis un jour
pour la nature et même plusieurs pour la
nature c'est quand même mieux pour que
tout ça puisse se régénérer et qu'on
puisse nous en profiter et que nos
enfants ou les générations futures
puissent en profiter
donc oui c'est le jeu c'est le jeu c'est
aujourd'hui on a moins de chances de mai
on en aura peut-être plus ou pas on
verra bien une campagne de rattrapage
quelque peu mitigé pour les marins
pêcheurs de st plus il y a deux mois il
avait été obligé d'arrêter prématurément
leur pêche faute de maturité des oursins
aujourd'hui ce sont les conditions en
mer qui sont mauvaises une situation qui
ne devrait pas s'améliorer demain avec
des prévisions de mer forte